welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Vasa and dr. sleep is the sequel to The
Shining an adaptation of Stephen King's
2013 sequel to his own shiny novel this
was a sequel that King wrote in part to
fix what he disliked about Stanley
Kubrick's 1980 masterpiece of shining
that's right it's been a long winding
road to this overlooked maze that we now
find ourselves in but hey it means we
get to terrify ourselves with some
nostalgic horror so sign me up
this sequel follows Danny Torrance as an
adult and ironically the story that King
wrote in protest of Kubrick's work is
loaded with Easter eggs and visual
Limoges - Kubrick's work why perhaps
because Stephen King has conceded that
sometimes outsider interpretations of
works are more entertaining than the
original works themselves or an example
this go check out new characters
breakdowns of the final season the game
of Thrones
I recently dove deep into Kubrick's The
Shining with an insane analysis to thank
our generous patrons for saving us from
homelessness if you're interested in
watching that which you should it's my
favorite breakdown that I've ever done
please consider becoming a patron
yourself and hit that patreon link in
the description below in this video I'm
going to go scene by scene throughout
dr. sleep to point out all the
interesting Easter eggs and shining
parallels that the directors snuck in
there for Dorian if you haven't seen dr.
sleep or The Shining yet let's get
started from the opening frames director
Mike Flanagan known for his work in the
hunting of Hill House on Netflix set out
to make a full love letter to Kubrick
we're Brothers logo appears under the
notes of Rachel Elkin and Wendy Carlos's
iconic synth score for the shining notes
that they adapted from the Gregorian
chant Adeus ear a day of wrath a funeral
song and then just like the Shining's
opening shots we get our first of many
aerial shots in dr. sleep this one
pointed directly down at a campsite in
1980 a young girl violet is lured in by
Rose the hat leader of a cult of vampire
like quasi immortals called the true not
they feed on the steam released by those
with the shine she and dr. sleep Stephen
King built on an already complex
mythology that included ghosts and
individuals with a psychic shine who can
see those ghosts now in addition to that
we got super old steam suckers just go
with it
roses attack seems very similar to other
classic horror kids snatchings Rose
lures in violet with a flower in a magic
trick
similar to how Pennywise lers George Lee
clothes with his paper boat so that he
can feed on him also this whole
waterfront flower exchanged evokes the
classic moment in the movie Frankenstein
moving on into the Overlook Hotel which
appears with
hexagonal pattern on screen that turns
into the famous second level carpet
pattern in Danny's memory he pedals his
big wheel past room 237 and this time
the door creaks open with the rotting
woman inside creepily looming in from
the blackness look considering Kubrick's
shining never really explicitly showed
me inside that room from Danny's
perspective this shot seems to deny the
many conspiracy theories about what
actually happened to Danny in that room
including the theory that Jack's
sexually abused Danny in there so after
moving to Florida
Danny remains haunted by that woman in
the tub he sucks his thumb and terror
just as he did as he walked up to windy
after the experiences in room 237 The
Shining windy here is played by Alex
Esso who does a pretty solid take on
Shelley Duvall though I think at one
point they sampled archive audio of
Duvall gasping Danny Danny meets with
the ghost of dick Halloran who
elaborates on his story of shining with
his grandmother to reveal that he had an
abusive grandfather just like Danny's
father he warns Danny to trap any ghosts
who haunt him inside a box in his mind
Danny's mind is depicted here as these
snowy hedge maze of the Overlook Hotel
extending Kubrick's metaphor of the maze
as a projection of the mind jack getting
lost in the maze reflected him losing
his grip of sanity Danny's story in
these inner demons in that maze reflects
him burying his past Flanagan uses
several drawn-out cross dissolves to
transition from scene to scene pay
homage to Kubrick's crest dissolves in
superimpositions throughout the shining
after in adulthood of alcoholism Dan
moves to a small town in New Hampshire
and gets a job working for Billy Freeman
in the town's teeny town it's a
miniature duplicate just like the
miniature version of the hedge maze and
the Overlook Lobby this is meant to show
how Dan is unable to run from the
Overlook he keeps finding himself
trapped back in these visual echoes of
the hotel my favorite example of this in
dr. sleep is Dan's interview in the
office of John Dalton Dan and Billy's a
group leader this set is an exact
replica of mr. Olens general manager
office and Overlook in a shining down to
the famous impossible window behind him
just like Jack Dan is destined to stand
the Overlook forever and ever
and long cross-dissolve ends on Dan
mopping just like a cross-dissolve
early on in the shining now working as a
hospice worker dan has found a calling
of using his shine to help the elderly
pass on the first man he does this for
is in room 217 a nod to King's novel in
which it was room 217 not 237 dan also
forms a psychic friendship with a young
girl Abra Abra witnesses the true not
feeding on a boy and uses her shine to
track rose linking with her in a grocery
store one point the word dairy is right
over roses shoulder obviously not the
same spelling as dairy main the setting
of it a number of Kings stories but on
calendar that's an easter egg dan is
also linked here and then he mentions
Tony his imaginary friend from his
childhood in the shining in King's novel
Tony is actually Danny's adult self from
the future warning him and now when dan
asks Tony for help no one responds
because Dan never grows older when they
all do remember the true not starves to
death
Rose comforts and by reminding him of
his super long life out living
civilizations she mentions skyscrapers
which could be a nod to a really dark
subplot in the dr. sleep book in which
Abra as a toddler predicts the 9/11
attacks and the true not visits Ground
Zero to feed off the steam of the
victims avarice family house number is
1980 the year The Shining was released
and the wall that Dan nabber used to
talk breaks into the word murder
reflecting as Redrum in Dan's mirror now
this is the opposite of the way the
mirror was used in the shining
Danny wrote Redrum on the door the
mirror reflected his true meaning murder
so it's reversed here to remind Danny of
the truth in the mirror reflection that
truth being Redrum the nonsense word he
wrote on the door in the Overlook
showing him the place he must eventually
return dan and Abra head to the Overlook
to trap rose Mike Flanagan actually
reused the exact footage of Kubrick's
opening aerial shots of Glacier National
Park rendering them now to look like
it's nighttime with falling snow this
film also throughout resamples shining
music editor Gordon stain for its
chilling sound design with the Eklund
chants and high-pitched shrieks Dan's
stroll through the hotel is shot in
these same camera movements that Kubrick
used
Steadicam tracking shots slow dollies
he's framed it just as his father was
through the crack in the door
and then he literally follows in his
father's footsteps to the Gold Room
where just like his father
he looks directly into the camera and
finds Lloyd the bartender except it's
not Lloyd from before it's a man who's
always been the caretaker here Jack
Torrance now jack is not played by Jack
Nicholson here he's played by Henry
Thomas collaborator if Flanagan from the
hunting of Hill House and a so grown-up
from playing Eliot in 80 dan struggles
against the whiskey temptation linking
his alcoholism with his father's and now
Kubrick shining very much down played
the role of alcoholism and Jack's
violent rampage
whereas Stephen King's version was very
much focused on the whole themes of
alcoholism and its links to family
violence Stan and a burr tried to trap
Rose in the Colorado lounge by Jack's
old Adler typewriter hoping to lock her
in another Mays box instead Rose stalk
stand up the stairs mirroring the way
Jack stalked Wendy up the stairs now
from here the shining references can hit
us over the head right there's a Grady
twins the room 237 woman horse to win
Delbert Grady they all show up to
consume Rose to get their fingers under
her skin it's kind of gross but awesome
whoo there's no sign from that creepy
bear costume and it all ends with Dan
overheating the boiler to burn down the
hotel which is actually how Stephen
King's shiny novel ends Dan's ghost
continues to visit Abra encouraging her
to shine on these final words date back
to Stephen King's inspiration for the
term The Shining John Lennon song
Instant Karma
aka we all shine on these words ring in
our mind as the credits close out with
the perfect song choice midnight the
stars in you the closing song shining
here do you think the doctor sleep film
was a worthy shining sequel comedy with
your thoughts follow me on twitter and
instagram at a vas and follow new rock
stars and socials at new rock stars and
subscribe to us on youtube for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching
[Music]